seven and settled in Baltimore where he
worked in the textile business and then
as a bookseller for many years mr. Brett
holds his life prior to his arrival in
the u.s. is chronicled in the memoir
leap into darkness it details his seven
years on the run during World War two
living often secretly in under false
names in Luxembourg Belgium and France
with relatives and friends being
imprisoned and escaping on several
occasions his talk is just under an hour
Holocaust survivor and co-author with
Michel Olesker of leap into darkness he
arrived in the United States in 1947 and
he settled in Baltimore where he worked
in the textile business and as a
bookseller he continues to relate his
real-life story of his multiple escapes
from the Nazis in wartime Europe to
audience all across the country in May
of 2001 Leo taught a course at the
senior adult summer Institute here at
HCC please help me welcome mr. Leo Brett
host
Thank You Joanne thank you for coming on
this afternoon for an hour or so of
sharing and and caring you're speaking
about a book here this is by the way not
the first time that I've been a this is
the third time at Howard Community
College so I have had my nice
experiences here before when we speak
about a book this book is leap into
doctrine this is a book festival that's
why I mentioned this normally I speak
about my events as part of the Holocaust
or show commemoration but being that is
ties in with the book I we have to dwell
on this at least for a little while it
came into being after I had many talks
with my friend Michael Alessi and he
said you know Leah your story is worth a
book said well I am NOT I'm working 9:00
to 5:00 and and in fact I'm working I'm
running a book store
so if I were going with this at the end
of the day are going into a busman's
holiday and then when I retired in 92 he
said you know you have no longer any
excuses and being that I had written
some op-ed pieces to the paper and some
essays he said you've got enough there
for a material for a book and so I sat
down and worked on it and wrote and I do
not type I wrote six hundred and sixty
pages legal
yellow legal paper lined paper in black
lettering and my friend Michael looked
at him and did some refining and did
some editing and we worked together
sometime late into the night and it
became leap into darkness which refers
to my escape from a train during night a
train that went from Paris France to
Auschwitz to the death came now
it developed and Michael in his
inimitable journalistic style learned a
lot with that my experience was my own
memory and that was a little hard for me
to recall all these events and emotional
naturally and he researched libraries
and books and history volumes and
learned a lot about that period in
history from 1938 to 1945 the end of the
war and every time I wrote my narrative
here my escape here I ran from here he
am going there what happened during that
period while I my little puny self tried
to save my life something more important
in my life must have happened then
namely a war and destructions of whole
populations they were in the realm of
history major events while my running
was just one fellow trying to save his
life and he inter move all these events
into my narrative so that it has become
a historic book actually where many
school districts in the United States
have taken it in as a required reader a
tool for Holocaust slash European
studies the Library Journal has given it
that why not write up and the the the
one the worldwide the Publishers Weekly
Publishers Weekly had given it that
right up so we were very fortunate that
it became that this is the background of
the book and of course it deals with my
many attempts to escape what did I try
to escape death I wanted to be ahead of
those who wanted me dead now this book
does not deal in atrocities in powers of
bodies in in all the terrible events
that happen but it deals with my efforts
to persevere
not to get to those scams it's
interesting some time I speak to schools
mr. Brett Rose do you have a number
unfortunately I cannot show you a number
because you would like to see it but
fortunately for me I don't have it
because had I been in a position to get
that number wherever they gave those
numbers I wouldn't be here speaking to
you so mine was not my book was not
about the atrocities but all the major
attempts to to survive and the
motivation was always fear fear
motivated me to little four-letter words
fear and then it had to be luck to
succeed so here we are I did not want to
get to Auschwitz of which we had heard
rumors what was Auschwitz ash which was
a realm to itself where death was not
the worst thing that could have happened
ash which was an event it was called the
kingdom of Auschwitz it was given that
moniker it was an event that after it
had happened and people started writing
about they couldn't find the proper
terms for it they had to invent new
vocabularies new words and they came up
with the word Holocaust coming from the
Greek Holocaust the Holocaust um which
means total destruction by burning fire
the English what caustic comes from it
and so on so that was Auschwitz and I
wanted to avoid that and I want to leave
you also with a little bit of insight
while we speak of Holocaust and this is
a term and now comes we'll April will
soon be here and this is the month where
show our Holocaust is being commemorated
all over the world in Israel day five
fly flags at half-staff and two minutes
silence and many areas in the world that
is being commemorated the word Holocaust
is just one term but when you want to
analyze it it consists of many facets
look at it it is history
it is religion it is politics
it is chemistry the camps
it is psychology political science and
philosophy transportation you know the
Germans while they were losing a war in
the East in 1943 and didn't have enough
transport material enough trains
available to resupply their forces in
Russia while they were losing a war
materiel ammunition clothing warm
clothing for the winter food they didn't
have enough trains to send that to their
troops to the Eastern Front to assure
them a victory perhaps there were offers
enough trains available to transport
Jews geography from the south of France
to no away to Greece to the AL of roads
all over the trains were converging on
the death camps that is that was the
Holocaust and I want to also dispel two
myths one of them is that Christians
didn't help us while it is true that the
hierarchy the church the institution
took a leave of absence that is has been
documented individuals did help
individuals yes and in my book this is
pointed out in several instances
individuals did help and the second
thing I want to dispel that we went to
our death almost voluntarily while
without resistance like lambs but you
know lambs is a good expression
what is a lamp it's the symbol for
innocence for for peace for trusting
yeah if we were trusting those who
deported us that at the end there will
still be some humanity yes we trusted in
them there will be humanity although I
gave up trusting that's why I ran away
that we believed yes that we went
with with with the idea that that nobody
can be that harmful that we will not be
armed innocent naive if you want to
equate that with lambs yes but without
resistance
no we resisted the Warsaw Ghetto fight
lest at 30 some days people without arms
against the superior army in the annals
of military history the Warsaw Ghetto
resistance by the Jews
goes down as a as a larger battle for
the Germans than Stalingrad in
proportion I give you another example a
handful of people in the ghetto without
arms 34 days Holland Belgium in France
together with armies didn't last that
long so we didn't resist and then when
we Forge false papers so that we can
move around freely
that's resistance when we help those who
are in hiding that's resistance when I
escaped from the train that was
resistance because I resisted those who
wanted me dead
and finally when I have survived
that's the utmost form of having
resistance this is the vindication so
these points I want to make before I go
into my story now one more thing the
Holocaust was not just happened the
Holocaust was planned it was planned in
the conference at Wednesday in 1942
didn't just happen and we think about it
as as one event but there was so much
involved in it and professor not
professor yeah professor V Street writes
about it he calls it that the longest
hatred
anti-semitism and the Catholic priest a
by the name of father Edward H Flannery
a Jesuit wrote a book the anguish of the
Jews 23 centuries of anti-semitism he
pointed it out and he said in a tempura
phrasing he said to say that Hitler's
persecution of the Jews and his attempt
to annihilate them is the most
horrifying event in the annals of Jewish
history is a trite understatement we
must consider it to be the most
horrifying event in the totality of
recorded history
therefore what Hitler did was only the
culmination of what had happened over
the centuries the early missionary said
we don't want you to live among us as
Jews so the Jews converted that they may
live among them then the later secular
Christians said you may not live among
us so the Jews went into ghettos to live
separated from them then came Hitler
it's the culmination and Hitler said you
may not live period and when the Jewish
star was introduced in France and in
Harlem and in Austria and Germany and
awards in France I had to wear this on
my lapel when this was instituted in the
40s in Europe it wasn't the first time
the first time that happened was in the
13th century in Oxford England before
the Jews were expelled so Hitler's
attempt with the Jews was only the
culmination of what had gone on for
centuries which brings me to my story
how did I get involved in that Cataclysm
event as I just described it it never
had before be never before had men acted
against his fellow man with more
ferocious
actions with more ferocity never before
so how did I get involved two simple
factors I was born into a Jewish family
in Austria in Vienna these are the two
factors I was born a Jew that was my
crime and I lived in Vienna as you know
Germany had become a dictatorship in
1933 and the restrictions against the
Jews were immediately instituted with
couldn't working the professionals
couldn't teach couldn't be judges all
the restrictions you know that but then
in 1938 when the Germans entered Austria
which was called the uncial so you're
familiar with the term Angelus that's
become an international term meaning
annexation when the Germans entered
Austria in 1938 in March of 38 hours
1017 the action against the Jews became
much more violent than the previous five
years in Germany and the Germans
realized that what we had done to the
Jews from 33 to 38 we need to make
improvements on that the austen's have
now shown us the way and I was there
when Hitler entered and millions
received the Germans not like the
Austin's later said we were the first
victims no that isn't true they were not
the first anything that happened in
Austria was dwarfed what had happened in
Germany before and overnight Jewish
males were being arrested our existence
from one day to the next descended into
utter chaos we were not allowed to walk
on the sidewalk we had to walk in the
gutter we couldn't shop in the stores
that we were used to shop we couldn't go
to our schools as Jews and as I said
the male population 16 to 60 arrested
never to be heard from again
and we saw that and my mother saw them
and I had two younger sisters
my mother had become a widow eight years
earlier my father had died when he was
39 I was nine years old and became by 38
had become the father image to my
younger sisters and therefore I was in
danger and I couldn't see myself leave
but my mother said this is not a place
for you you must leave Austria
you must leave Vienna the city that you
were born in because of what you seen
are the Austin's are funny people they
tell you they tell you Hitler was German
and Beethoven was Austrian you know it's
the other way around but that's the way
Austria is it's endemically so and I was
happy living in Vienna I was and it
wasn't easy for me to contemplate what
my mother had just suggest that you must
leave
but arrangements were made for me to
leave an aunt and uncle had emigrated a
few months earlier gone to Luxembourg
and they had worked on it to arrange for
me to come to Luxembourg a committee
Jewish Aid Committee had helped and
correspondence between my aunt and my
mother and in October of 1938 I left
Austria and over 17 and a half before I
left I visited my ten year old sister my
youngest sister she was then confined in
a hospital with scarlet fever in
quarantine and we went to visit her and
she was at the mezzanine window my
mother and I in a rainy afternoon
standing there looking at his
ten-year-old and
I told her in a contrive sign language I
will be leaving she understood and she
had a blackboard a piece of chalk in a
hand and wrote on it
good luck we'll see you soon again and
as I say in the book she looked then
like the last angel on earth with her
curly black hair and her dark eyes and
you know when we said goodbye and then
all these men were arrested that's why I
left it was never in our mind you could
not have conceived at that time that
four years later it would be the turn
for women and children to be arrested
entered our minds why and why not
this was the twentieth century this was
the nation of poets and thinkers
this wasn't Attila the Hun or Genghis
Khan or such times poets and thinkers we
said goodbye and are often it's like a
mantra in here it'll be all right
everything will be all right but little
did we know then that it wouldn't be all
right and I arrived at the border town
of three atria near the border of
Luxembourg and Germany and I was
arranged for me but a committee to spend
five nights with Franciscan friars in a
monastery entry in the town of Trier
you're familiar with three Oh perhaps in
the Moselle Valley beautiful country
vineyards the Moselle peacefully flowing
through that Valley spend five nights
with the Friars
and it rained for five days and when the
smuggler came to pick me up a mr. Becker
came to pick me up to take me over to
Luxembourg he was a Luxembourger and he
could travel freely between Luxembourg
in Germany his papers legal picked me up
and he asked me do you know how to swim
yes well I was going to cross the sour a
stream that goes from the other entrance
into the valley a a tributary of the
Moselle River normally a placid mountain
stream and I was told that I'll be able
to for that up to my knees and Becker
says can you swim yes of course I said
we'll have been be necessary well he
didn't want to discourage me he says but
it may be you know but I want to tell
you something you take you have some dry
socks with you say I have a change of
clothes in my little at the shake cases
about put those dry socks into your top
coat I was fully closed
you know what knickerbockers do everyday
stylish I cross I crossed the room that
that I crossed that border in style you
see knickerbockers and a blue gabardine
coat I put those socks as per his
instructions into my pockets of the top
coat he left me at the embankment said
meet you on the other side he went there
said I'll be riding up and down that
road blinking my lights because it was
nighttime I was the night from October
the 31st to November the first it was
All Saints in Europe or Saints night you
know here it's Halloween and topped me
off and I walked down the embankment and
here with my dry socks and my partner
took one step into that stream into that
stream which was now a torrent because
it carried 9 5 days of rain into the
valley with mud and debris and branches
and treat treat parts you know I took
the first step into that river and I was
up to my waist in water now here because
good intentions of twice Lux went by the
wayside
they were
a dry but I had to cross that River and
I didn't need much effort because the
current carried me the only thing I
needed give myself directions to get to
the other side and here my mother comes
to my mind and that was constantly with
me doing these seven years on the run in
wartime Europe my mother comes to my
mind take care be safe don't do this
careful she wanted me in safety and here
I'm in this river taking chances if she
would know that in my mind she would
probably say I shouldn't have sent you
away and across that river and arrived
in Luxembourg and nine days later this
same smuggler mr. Beckett took me and
five other people north to Belgium
because you couldn't stay in Luxembourg
and it was arranged for me to go to
Antwerp Belgium we crossed the border
into Belgium during the night of
November the 9th of November the 10th
that was christened in in Europe night
of the broken glass and one man in the
car glimpse glimpsed the East and said
look what I see spoke Yiddish look what
I see he glimpsed the east and they all
looked into that direction and we saw in
the distance strange flickerings in the
skies they strange colorations and and
and and various shadings and something
we had never seen before me didn't know
what to make of it until the next day
when we arrived in Luxembourg in in
Brussels in Belgium and we were put into
a hotel in the hotel lobby the
newspapers displayed there had the
headlines proclaiming night of terror in
Germany meet the devil on all Manya
program control age with a program
against the Jews and I read this a new
little friends and I see Berlin
Frankfurt Hamburg Dresden Vienna and I
see what had happened in Vienna
in Germany all over close to 300
synagogues burned down in one night and
destruction departments to us apartments
killings arrests and again my thought
flashed respect to my mother she would
need me now what am I doing here in
Brussels looking down on the street with
the normal traffic hits going to school
in people about their daily routine to
work and in cars and covered in street
cars and here I am feeling like a heel I
have abandoned them and immediately I
had to think differently my mother
wanted me in safety and I am in safety
this is what you wanted for me and there
was no going back anyway so it was just
I was just sort of fantasizing I stayed
in Belgium for 18 months and considered
that my temporary shangri-la because
everything was peaceful in Belgium I
received temporary residential papers
for a refugee from Germany then it was
Germany already that I'm not no longer
Austria and I was there till Maine the
10th 1940 from November 38 to me as you
know in September 39 the Germans
attacked Poland and World War 2 broke
out the attack took place on the 1st of
September embed a 3rd of September
England and France had declared war on
Germany between that time and the 10th
of May there was a situation was called
la vall de guerre in French the funny
war because the soldiers faced each
other in the West especially near the
marginal line Maginot Line the
fortifications between France and
Germany
they didn't fight the guns were stacked
they played soccer exchanged chocolates
cigarettes play chess
no fighting was called and royal de
guerre until May the 10th when the
Germans
the west blitzkrieg France Belgium
Luxembourg Luxembourg always
traditionally a neutral nation and
little Luxembourg they were overrun
I was arrested on May the 10th in
Antwerp as a enemy alien on Middleton
the night before the attack I had
entered the hospital in Antwerp to have
a hernia repair I was prepared for the
operation to take place the next morning
on May the 10th at 7 o'clock it never
took place
because at 6 o'clock that morning the
German bombers flew over Antwerp and
dropped incendiary bombs all over the
place in fact a couple of them fell into
the courtyard of that hospital the
windows were blown out and immediately
civil defence in their white helmets
appeared gave instructions and the the
PA system advised us to come to the
office those of you who are ambulatory
can walk on their own power come to the
office collect your documents and we
will give you instructions as to how
negotiate your way home in this
bombardment that was all taken care of
and I had to leave the hospital they
were getting ready to receive people who
may have been hurt wounded whatever
during the bombardment I was arrested
and against my pleadings and so with
many many others we could not make
headway with the police this is
international protocol you get it you
come from a country that has just
invaded you so you an enemy alien I
became an enemy alien and I tried to
reason with the police you see we were
the we they they were our enemies before
they just became yours so we are on the
same page we are the same both be on the
same side we can fight with you no
cellar
Salwa that's the law and several hundred
of us were arrested and sent to southern
France it took five days to get down to
near the Pyrenees something like five
six hundred miles and we the train went
there was a
passenger train but sealed through some
of the errors that we are being bombed
in northern France and we had to stop
several times and and it was a it was a
very difficult trip down there but we
were getting out of the war zone we went
to a camp called San Supriya and yet a
Spanish border now beautiful now if I
were an artist if I were their owner
Hana on a pleasure trip I couldn't have
picked us a nicer spot you know the
majestic Pyrenees and the blue
Mediterranean merging meeting a cobbler
but this came sansa Priam was a hellhole
it had served for the Spanish refugees
during the Civil War from 36 to 39 and 9
1940 it was used for us who had come
from the north as enemy aliens but we
were Jews and in this camp very soon
dysentery broke out and typhus and the
gods relaxed their watchfulness they
didn't wanna catch this being in
proximity of the of the internees so
they relaxed their watchfulness taking
advantage advantage of that with the
help of a friend who had found out about
the camp outside in Toulouse came to
visit me and he said to me Leo you know
what there is a way for you to get away
from here suppose these cards these
cards never mind they walk around they
don't they don't do anything they just
walk as long as you can manage I'll show
you where and he was there to show me
where to get under the barbed wire clan
crawl under it it's all in detail you'll
be I'm going to my time element might
soon be over so I will just tell you I
escaped from that camp in San Syria and
made my way into a little town where I
knew some of my friends were had come
from the north from Belgium and
incorporated myself with all the other
refugees that had come from the north
from Holland Belgium northern France and
elseís Lorraine and Luxembourg and I was
not part of that mass of refugees that
had arrived
in June of that year France capitulated
to the Germans an armistice was signed
and France was split into two parts the
northern part including the west coast
under German control in the southern
part under the control of a newly
installed collaborationist government in
the town of Vichy headed by marshal
Peeta and it was from that moment on
called Vichy France or a non occupied
were controlled all kinds of euphemisms
but they took orders from the Germans
and it wasn't long before the Vichy
French instituted violent anti-jewish
laws now here you have the country of
poets and thinkers Germany combining
with the country of liberté égalité a
fraternity the country that gave the
world the notion of revolution in La
Marseillaise these two ball works of
civilization and culture combined with
the worst anti-jewish laws Europe had
ever seen and Vichy France established
some of these anti-jewish laws many of
us were sent into places that was they
were called forced residences residence
foxi or residence a singie
for those who know a little French
assigned or forced residences near the
Spanish border little towns where we
were concentrated had no right to leave
without any special permit and these
permits were never given and had to go
to the police every two weeks to to
register if not we wouldn't get our
ration cards say and couldn't go into
Spain because there was closed up with
barbed wire that was in 1940 and 41 in
1942 the deportations of Jews from
France began in the north in Paris and
all the other regions in the north and
the rumors ran rampant already that they
are going to a camp in the east where
the
being murdered but many people wouldn't
believe it but those who believed who
were some were not quite satisfied with
what what we heard took this for granted
and I did I didn't like what I heard I
have been in touch with my mother on and
off through a cousin who lived in
Switzerland she sent him the letters he
sent it to me to France because there
was no direct communication and in 1942
in August of 42 Vichy France began
deportations of Jews in earnest in the
town where I was confined as a refugee
forced residents we heard in that town
through a messenger from the mayor that
there will be a raid he was a good guy
and some of us took to the mountains we
hid out for two nights then came into
the valley and half of the Jewish
population that was confined there had
already been taken away I had no way any
longer to stay in that little place
because I couldn't go and collect and
register and and collect my my my ration
cards because I was then illegal because
my name was on the list of those who
were supposed to have been arrested a
left coat array that's in the in the
Pyrenees that little town of coat array
and with false IDs made my way into
Switzerland crossed the country with a
friend of mine whose name was Albert
into Switzerland I crossed into
Switzerland to quite some time and when
we were up there in the mountain and
looked down on Lake Geneva another
beautiful scenery I saw beautiful things
but couldn't enjoy them
because there was no tomorrow you could
never see tomorrow and there was Lake
Geneva
thus the lights of Switzerland
reflecting in its waters and my freedom
was at arm's reach all I had to do is
cross that little rivulet that the
smuggler told me I have to cross to get
into Switzerland that was easy
I was I was home free
right Albert and I crossed into
Switzerland and were arrested on our
mountain paths before we reached a
valley taken down to the valley where a
sergeant treated us abominably wooden
here wouldn't want to hear anything and
sent us back to Vichy France there was
Switzerland the land the neutral country
sent us back and what we later heard was
that many of the deportation trains that
went from France and Italy to Auschwitz
crossed Switzerland and Switzerland did
not a protest so their neutrality was
just flim-flam we were sent back to
Vichy France and went to a camp called
reef site and reef site was just about
20 miles from the original from the
original San Supriya so there were two
years that had gone by two and a half
years had gone by and had come full
circle without making any progress I was
back in a camp in Vichy France two weeks
later a hundred nine of us were sent up
to the north to a camp called
the one seen near Paris in northeast of
Paris a suburb and that camp held close
to 80,000 internists on their way to
Auschwitz it was a transit camp
Taurasi is this in this book but the
class felt it is chronicled it's called
the memorial that the post challenge if
de France the memorial to the
deportation of Jews from France
it contains close to 80,000 names all
the transports from France to Auschwitz
my name is in this book in transport
number 42 on the 6th of November 1942
were it not for that night when I
escaped I wouldn't be speaking to you
over 80,000 people or close to 80,000
people less than 2,000 are known to have
survived those who have survived have a
little dot next to their name and they
are fine in between and my name has no
doc next to it that means this book
lists me as one who was gassed in
Auschwitz it's all described in leap
into darkness why because when this book
was done in 78 in Paris by the class
felt the class wells are the people who
were the Nazi hunters BIA Beatrice
Piatti and and her husband Serge they
were responsible for bringing a Klaus
Barbie the butcher of Lyon back to
France extradited from Bolivia to France
and of course Barbie when he was
sentenced and after his sentence was
asked if he had any regrets
he said yes I regret that we didn't
finish it this is one for the deniers
all they have to do ask some of the Nazi
SS and they will tell him yes we did it
and we wish we had finished it my name
is in here I want to show something else
the oldest person deported from Branson
and listed here so the oldest person was
born in 18-49 she was 94 years old she
was an enemy of the German you see the
youngest were people born on kids
infants born on the same day that they
were thrown into a carica often without
their mothers and these are the scenes
that are witnessed in the strain in our
train every train had a thousand 20 cars
fifty each the old the very old the just
born handicapped going to the east
a human cargo all but abandoned by the
world my friend and I decided my friend
Manfred not Albert Albert was in the
train with me too but he couldn't escape
he was too voluminous he had a paunch
when I said Albert you're going with us
he says but he was a tender soul he was
there leaning and humming Italian folk
tunes he was a tenor in that cattle car
with me was a woman maybe 60 with deep
set eyes
streaky gray hair holding a four year
old child on her lap that child wasn't
hers she was on crutches in when a
friend and I prepared to escape and that
was feverish attempt working hard a
whole day and some people tried to talk
us out of it she says don't let anybody
talk you out of it she pointed that
crotch at us and emboldened us with
these words you must do it may God watch
over you could you evoke a stir that's
what she said
and my friend and I made our getaway you
see it was an awful situation that way
in that cattle car there was one bucket
for 50 people I'll leave it to you that
we were waiting in human waste and
squatting the whole gamut of emotions in
that cattle car crying moaning giving up
encouragement by some praying my friend
and I made our get away from that cattle
car and the first night after that we
spent with a priest now here you come
again he let us stay overnight and we
got to his sacristy we had torn off our
stars that says this does as chief Jew
France and he won't know what we what we
would like we escaped from that train we
told him he says oh yes Isis they come
by here three times a week you escape
from the Train like this he says well
what can I do what we would like to
spend the night he says well you know
there are these these patrols that come
by every morning early if I let you stay
would have to leave very early that's
fine but before we talk any further he
says why don't you go to that bathroom
and use some soap and water
you know we couldn't stand our own smell
and he and and he was aware so you know
we wound up that night sleeping under a
comforter a down comforter with crisp
white sheets we hadn't seen a sheet or a
shower in months and you woke us next
morning gave us a letter to a colleague
of his some 1015 miles away and we
hitched a ride with a hay wagon and you
got to that clergyman and he let us stay
for the night again and we stayed in a
stable he had a farm and his sacristy a
little church and a stable and there
were two cows in that stable and Manfred
and I spent the night sleeping between
these two cows any of you ever tried
that is the warmest coziest most
sheltered feeling no German will look
here what would they want in a stable
you know chewing the card and lulling us
to sleep cosy I'm thinking of it as as a
moment of it's beautiful
try it sometime please we made our way
to Paris and later down to southern
France
I have an aunt in Paris she was hiding
out and I searched there out through our
concierge and she wanted me to stay in
Paris
you stay here don't leave Paris awhile
you sent your son away she's ever he's a
kid you stay with me you'll survive the
war together I wanted to go down to
southern France with my friend where he
had left his brother and why I had left
a girlfriend by the way so you know
that's an attraction there
we arrived in southern France and today
my aren't a visitor in 99 and she's now
96 god bless her the first thing she
said to me when we visited her in Paris
Ananda
you should have stayed in Paris you see
that's her mantra we arrived in southern
France and I was arrested I was arrested
in southern France and sent to jail and
tried I was tried for abandoning and
assigned residence you remember I ran
away as the Baroness and one year in
jail nine months of good behavior which
makes it I mean three months of a
quarter of a good behavior which makes
it nine months in jail and after my
trial I escaped from the Sondheim's and
they caught me two days later and beat
me up something awful and they added two
days to my sentence
we had come out of the courthouse and
the Jean Dom's instead has taken me to
the train station where we would go back
to the jail it was winter it was January
and there was no heating so instead of
waiting for the train to depart within
an hour they took me to a bistro they
sat down to have a glass of wine and I
was handcuffed to a woman who was there
for
marketeering and Samir go to the
bathroom the son answers oh yes and he
left the handcuffs on me like a souvenir
you see and the woman was sitting next
to him the woman was black market theory
now went into the bathroom and guess
what the best tomato window so that was
my getaway
why afraid fear again the lawyer said to
me about you and jail for nine months
you'll be off the streets you won't be
arrested and sent to tossie again I said
yeah but what if there is an attack on a
German or on the French melis that works
with the Germans and somebody gets
killed they come to jail take out 50
hostages and the first ones they take
are the Jews and the resistance fighters
says what you got yeah that's possible
but you've taken less of a chance for
that to happen then oh be in the streets
and be arrested when they ask you for
your papers so that's why I pleaded
guilty and went to jail but as I said I
escaped they caught me two days later
after my liberation after my I was
released from jail in September of 1943
I was sent to a hard labor camp in set
form in southwestern France spent a
month there and on the 11th of October
1943 14 of us were taken to what was
then ostensibly told us to the Western
Front to the western coast to build
fortifications may I remind you still
have my hernia and me going to build
fortifications I wouldn't have I
wouldn't I'm going to live through it
carrying cement bags and wheelbarrows I
was afraid to wind up back into Aussie
where a second escape would be nearly
impossible I escaped from that train a
standing train this time in the train
station of Toulouse and my friend with
whom I had escaped originally we were in
touch forged some papers for me a birth
certificate and from that moment on I
joined the French Resistance and lived
with a French identity a my nom de
guerre was only Henri Lefebvre and I
lived with these false papers to the end
of the war in May of 1944 I was assigned
then to a unit in Limoge
I was on my way with false ID cards that
we produce produced to take him to an
orphanage I collapsed in the streets of
the Toulouse in the streets of limos
with a strangulated hernia and lay on
apartments throwing up violently and a
woman walks by and I look up and I see
she has a Red Cross here she says young
man you had too much to drink too much
wine total I said no I didn't drink I
have a hernia if you have you act like
this you have a hernia you need a
hospital
but I had nothing to say I was afraid to
get a hospital again being there under
sedation
not knowing who is in charge of me
recognising me being Jewish and with
false papers and whatever
I was afraid again but I had nothing to
in the hands of people whom at the
moment I had to trust and this was the
most vulnerable moment of my life we
already had heard that soon the landing
might take place through the through the
communications with with the resistance
of coded messages that was main the
landing of course took place on June the
6th 1944 the next morning I wake up in
that hospital bed and a voice whispers
into my ear as long as I am in this ward
you have nothing to fear do you can you
visualize can you sense what that meant
for me at that moment as I said the most
vulnerable moment in that whole period
of running you have nothing to fear my
name is Jean Dalek Joan of Arc I'm your
nurse among this hospital st. Vincent's
bus staffed by religious nuns evidently
the other nurses the nuns of the
Immaculate Conception as nurses you have
nothing to fear and as I was writing
this in leap into darkness I got choked
up and now I've said to me Leo why don't
you write to that Hospital in jail le
marché find out if they know whatever
happened to sister Joan of Arc
said well you know 44 this was 98 she's
what you got to lose so I did and I
received an answer sister Joan of Arc
was with us till 1965
her name is sedan gave me her last name
she is now in a retreat for aging nuns
in the city of Castro in southern France
not far from Toulouse fact not far from
the town where last escape try to write
to her wish you good luck I did two
weeks later I received a letter from
Jean d'Arc
and we're still corresponding last week
a center of a letter in response to one
of hers she writes like a poetess she's
not ninety but better yet in 1999 when
my wife and I went back to France to
retrace my steps step by step to all the
places where I was hiding to the jail
where was imprisoned and they made me
copies of my documents and to visit
sister Joan of Arc in Harry trades in we
were treated to dinner and we were
treated to breakfast we stayed overnight
we had separate rooms yes I was
emotional and we took pictures
Joan of Arc and I
after 55 years someone says she held you
she wanted to bridge a gap of 55 years
and this is this is what made the but
they've made that worthwhile for the
book to have been written you see there
should have never been a reason for it
to be written because those times that
I'm telling about we're not normal times
there were times of depravity it should
have never had a reason but being that
was written this is one of the fringe
this is one of the of the side effects
ancillary product of the book that made
it worthwhile so all I have to say is
that hatred is still with us we know
that we have learned hatred is
all-consuming we have learned that in
the last half a year as I told you I
swam a river I climbed the mountain for
72 hours where the next morning I
couldn't take my socks off my feet they
were glued to my bloody feet I escaped
from a train and from another train I
submit to you that the hardest wall to
climb and to overcome is the wall of
hatred all these things that I did out
of fear evidently I was lucky to survive
my mother and sisters were not we lost a
million and a half children
hatred the wall of hatred cannot be
overcome as easily as what I did
in hindsight that's easier than hatred
and I leave it to you to to carry that
message somebody speaks to you about
somebody else in in terms of derogation
a hatred race religion nationality you
have to immediately tell that person I
am NOT on the same page with you look
for another companion in your in your
hatred because the hater never he or she
never thinks the haters never think that
they are wrong they always feel they're
right and if you do not stand up and
talk back immediately they feel that
they are right because you have no
answer when you walk away you give them
credibility this is the message I want
to leave you with I want to thank you
for your patience for coming and for
sharing and for listening and go in good
health I thank you very much
so that we can I'd like to know where we
can buy your book it will be available
in a few minutes the lady wants to know
where where you come by the we brought a
few along we have the paper back which
is Doubleday Random House which is
twelve dollars even and then we have a
heart pack which is the British Edition
the American edition is sold out
eventually
it will be done perhaps again the heart
bag will be there will be another print
run but I have the British Edition in
hardback which is twenty dollars I thank
you very much okay
one comment quickly to make I exercise
with a man who recently published a book
similar to yours called one step ahead
that's mr. fellows that's correct I read
the book have you read this
okay I have not but I know him and I've
talked with him extensively and Alfred
Phil that's right he lives in Colombia
but I think he's 9 Europe he went visit
that's right he went to visit one of the
people who helped him yes thank you very
much very common anybody else be glad to
answer a few questions
that means that we have concluded the
afternoon thank you have a good day
you're watching a special lineup of book
TV on c-span 2 featuring books about
world war 2 book TV can normally be seen
each Saturday and Sunday on this network
for more information